[Musique]
ici à winnipeg l'écriture fait des
pièges c'est vraiment du bas ici en lui
ni peine s'il ya une croissance de
population philippine l'armé du crime
unit pex et la ville avec le plus de
philippe et par habitant parmi les
grandes villes au canada
now daigneault parmesan solide et fils
comme eto'o et à winnipeg la 12e langue
maternelle la plus courante après
l'anglais ce n'est pas français c'est le
tagalog l'une des langues
[Musique]
on est en train d'atteindre à la
commande à le toucher jo libye c'est une
chaîne de restaurants si l'américain
avec une influence philippines est
considéré comme le mcdonald's
philippines
c'est à winnipeg que le premier restera
jo libye a été ouvert au canada en 2016
[Musique]
l'une des raisons pour laquelle la
chaîne a choisi winnipeg comme premier
lieu pour s'établir au canada c'est
l'importance de sa communauté philippine
pourquoi la ville de winnipeg hôtel une
population philippine
si importante on en discute avec
johnatan malek docteur en histoire il
étudie la communauté philippine depuis
plus de 10 ans entre les années 50 et 70
des professionnels de la santé philippe
un incapable d'immigrés aux états unis
s'installe à winnipeg ils obtiennent le
statut de résident permanent
les visons en main goncourt sont
importants dans le secteur de la santé
et du textile
selon john on assiste alors à un
recrutement actif la manitoba goldman
association une association du textile
se rend directement à manille la
capitale des philippines grand gaucher
des travailleurs en majorité des femmes
qui parraine le reste de leur famille ni
nazi et en 1998 le manitoba lançant
programme pour les migrants qui
souhaitent s'installer au manitoba et
soutient ensuite leur candidature au
gouvernement fédéral et aux de sa jolie
vague de froid
et aujourd'hui l'influencent philippines
est notoire à winnipeg
on retrouve des médias spécialisés dans
l'actualité des philippines comme le
filippino john holmes est une émission
matinale nommé good morning meeting
[Musique]
et sur la scène culturelle
on peut même voir une comédie musicale
dont la distribution est entièrement
philippines et depuis 2012 la communauté
philippine célèbre ses origines lors
d'un défilé annuel
[Applaudissements]
la communauté fait aussi la promotion
des philippines lors de phoques leur âme
à un festival qui met de l'avant le
multiculturalisme au manitoba explique
rami lesbien pompiers l'un contient des
pipots watine normal folklorama c'est
notamment l'occasion d'en apprendre sur
la nourriture des philippines et de
rencontrer de jeunes ambassadeurs qui
arbore fièrement des vêtements
traditionnels des philippines et baroque
ça y est
[Musique]
bref des éléments culturels des
philippines sont devenus des
incontournables à winnipeg dont la
communauté est très fier je dirais que
les philippines ont comme une telle
fierté dans leur culture dans leur
langue
la communité public et aidé à contribuer
à leur économie
et puis aussi aussi à la sociabilité
je pense que les fils klino ajoute
beaucoup de nos diversités à notre
communauté et anémone nous sommes d hab
calciné jean thomas amusant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]